[Music]
in this problem a water quality engineer
is determining the max concentration of
a compound that can be released into a
water supply the following data are
provided the no observed adverse effect
level Noel for this compound was found
to be
14.28 mg per kilog day it was assumed
that the average person weighed 70 kg
and would consume 2 L of water per day
an uncertainty fact factor of 10 was
applied for inters species differences
between the test animals and humans and
another uncertainty factor of 10 is
applied to account for variation in
human
sensitivity what should the maximum
contaminant level goal or mclg be for
this compound in drinking water in
milligrams per
liter so in this problem the first thing
we need to do is to find the equations
we need if we search Noel in the
reference manual this will bring us to
section 6.7.8 titled risk
calculation the reference manual
provides two equations that are required
for this
problem the first is the reference dose
which
equals the
Noel divided by the uncertainty
Factor the second is the
dwe or drinking water equivalent
level which is the reference
dose times body
weight divided by drinking water
consumption or
dwc to shorten
that next let's write out our know and
what we are looking for so the problem
gives us the Noel already
and that is going to be
14.28 millgram
per kilogram
day the body weight used in the
study was given as 70
kg and the drinking water consumption
we're going to shorten to
dwc is given as 2 L per
day there are two uncertainty factors
given we can write out uf1 =
10 and
uf2 =
10 and finally we're being asked to
find the maximum contaminant level goal
or
mclg
so what does it take to solve this
problem now that we have everything we
need laid out first we need to realize
that the mclg we are asked to solve for
is actually the term
dwel in one of our
equations next we need to recognize that
while we aren't given the reference dose
we are given the terms that comprise
this variable so let's rewrite our
equation to include those terms
instead
now all we have to do is plug in our
given and solve the
problem so
mclg is going to be
14.28 millgram
per kilogram
Day
times 70
kg
over our first uncertainty factor of 10
times our second uncertainty factor of
times our drinking water
consumption of 2 L per
day and if we solve this
out first of all we can cancel some
units to determine that we're in the
right units
still and we can see here that the end
result is milligrams per liter and our
answer is just about
five which we can see is one of our
answers over
here so this problem is actually very
easy to solve if you know a few things
one you need to know where your
equations come from in the manual two
you need to recognize that the mclg
equals the
dwel and three you need to understand
how to manipulate the equation for
reference dose to go into the equation
for
dwe and finally you need need to
recognize that both uncertainty factors
need to be used to account for the total
uncertainty used in coming up with this
standard and that's
it